[Musique]
qui vous inspirent et quand vous aviez
dix ans qui était votre super-héros au
super héroïne qui avaient des super
pouvoirs sans limite qui pouvait
peut-être repousser les méchants de la
planète faire le bien ou encore
accomplir des exploits sportifs
c'était peut-être superman qui savaient
voler ou bien son goku tu pouvais
repousser les méchants de la planète
ou alors en très grand sportif comme
michael jordan
moi mon super héros il voulait que nous
soyons tous égaux sans distinction il
osait dire ce qui dérangeait ce qui
choquait sur toutes les ondes télé et
radios du monde entier c'est à dire un
monde qui souffrent que nous devons
soigner tous ensemble
[Musique]
jen sont dé port au prince pour art
hogan the world
dean cain retail price c'est le message
qu'il portait il ya plus de 30 ans à nos
oreilles
et c'est le même message que je porte ce
soir devant vous non pas que je sois
haute koulou vitesse ou nostalgiques
bien que mais c'est que malheureusement
ce message est toujours d'actualité
j'ai effectivement une mauvaise et une
bonne nouvelle pour nous le constat est
que nous sommes plus de 7 milliards à
peupler cette magnifique planète plein
de ressources
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que ces
ressources ne sont pas illimitées ne
sont pas équitablement distribués
plus concrètement un humain sur sept
souffre de malnutrition et coulé tant
carences nutritives 600 millions de
personnes soit près de dix fois la
population de la france
chaque jour nous coupons 10 millions
d'arbres de nos forêts qui ne sont pas
illimitées nous polluons et empoisonnant
notre faune et flore marines avec les 8
millions de tonnes de plastique que nous
rejetons chaque année dans notre ferme
et on peut également continuer à parler
du déclin des abeilles des insectes ou
encore de nos mammifères marins et
terrestres
nous sommes en train de vivre la sixième
extinction de masse mais qui dit animaux
océans ou forêts ne veut pas dire pour
autant que l'être humain est épargné
loin de là réfléchissons ensemble aux
besoins des êtres humains
nous avons besoin de nous nourrir
de respirer de boire de l'eau potable
est d'avoir un toit n'est ce pas donc
nos besoins mange et boit respire et
dépend de notre environnement nous
devons alors le protéger ça me rappelle
une citation de gandhi qui disait déclin
des abeilles qui disait en fait la
planète a suffisamment de ressources
pour satisfaire les besoins humains mais
malheureusement pas assez pour assouvir
notre cupidité
car en effet nous devons changer
mais pourquoi la terre à plus de 4
milliards d'années elle a vécu non pas
une non pas deux non pas trois non pas
quatre non pas cinq mais train train de
vivre sa sixième extinction de masse
donc qui est en danger
la planète où l'humanité c'est bien
l'homme qui doit changer
protéger son habitat être plus solidaire
c'est une question de survie
alors je ne suis pas devant vous ce soir
pour vous annoncer l'apocalypse loin de
là je fais partie justement de ceux qui
voient le verre à moitié plein car oui
en effet face à cette mauvaise nouvelle
j'ai également une bonne nouvelle il se
trouve qu'à travers le monde
il existe des personnes qui trouvent des
solutions face à nos limites face aux
limites de notre existence
d'ailleurs c'est une double bonne
nouvelle pour moi car j'en ai fait mon
métier je fais du journalisme d'impact
c'est à dire je vais uniquement
interviewer les gens qui changent le
monde si porteur de solutions d'un monde
meilleur
d'ailleurs ce soir mais changelog heures
d'ailleurs ce soir j'aimerais vous
parler de ma plus jeune rencontre il y a
un an et demi je me suis rendu à chicago
et j'ai rencontré jack hill jackson 10
ans
femme de basket-ball donc de michael
jordan chacun son michael de break dance
mais aussi de claquettes est à son
niveau il a également décidé de soigner
la planète
qu'est ce qu'il a fait à votre avis il
devance baladant dans les rues de sa
ville
à chicago il a vu qu'il y avait des sdf
tout comme chez nous en france et il
s'est dit qu'est ce que je peux faire et
bien écrit son association
deux ans auparavant il en avait 8 qui a
pour but de distribuer des blessing
backs des sacs de charité brosse à dents
dentifrice savons rasoir un kit pour lui
améliorer leur quotidien leurs
conditions de vie
jackie jackson ne s'est pas donner de
limites pour agir mais bien des
objectifs pour aider sa communauté
il a refusé de voir le fatalisme sous
ses yeux c'est à dire la pauvreté et
agir
il se trouve que ces objectifs ont fait
parler de lui les journaux nationaux
américains en parlons du ou parler de
lui il est devenu une figure inspirante
pour la jeunesse et sans le vouloir il a
eu les reconnaissances de son ancien
président jackie jackson
barack obama vous l'avez reconnu jackie
jackson ne s'est pas donner de limites
pour agir on peut dire qu'il est écouté
son coeur et qu'il a pu changer le monde
à son échelle en refusant de fatalis
même à dix
maintenant je vous embarque avec moi
direction la savane
cette fois ci pour parler de d'autres
sdf il ya quelques mois je me suis rendu
au kenya en fille qui porte des qui
porte les pays sur elle je me suis rendu
au kenya donc oui je rencontrais les
massaï mais malheureusement dans ces
pays où il existe notamment des
éléphants il existe aussi le commerce
illégaux égal de l'ivoire on assiste
donc le coz le commerce illégal de
l'ivoire c'est jeu massacre les les
éléphants pour leur défense pour en
faire des objets de luxe notamment pour
le marché asiatique
donc en clair en afrique on assiste au
déclin de ce pachyderme majestueux
plus grand mammifère terrestre ici la
limite c'est le nombre d'individus
il reste que quelques milliers d'
éléphant sur les terres africaines
ce qui fait que ça devient une espèce en
voie d'extinction mais effectivement
face aux limites vous connaissez vous
avez compris maintenant il ya des
challenges mais coeur pour trouver des
solutions et heureusement au kenya
depuis plus de 40 ans il existe en
orphelinat qui s'occupe des éléphanteaux
victimes du trafic illégal de l'ivoire
the david celle vue ou à l'afp trust
depuis 40 ans cet orphelinat nourrit
swan est réintroduit dans leur habitat
naturel ces éléphanteaux ici aussi
cet orphelinat comme jackie jackson à
l'échelle sociale refuse le fatalisme de
la disparition de notre biodiversité et
agissent avec des milliers de donateurs
depuis plus de 40 ans à travers le monde
pour lutter contre la cupidité humaine
être un challenge make her say osé
dépasser ses limites des limites de la
société pour agir pour l'améliorer se
rendre utile être plus généreux
c'est refuser le fatalisme en créant des
solutions en important des auditions en
agissant être un challenge mais coeur ça
avoir une vision long terme east sur
notre monde pour qu'il soit plus juste
plus solidaire plus égalitaire cette
chaîne the maker façonnent le monde de
demain même d'aujourd'hui c'est vous
c'est nous alors peut-être que certains
d'entre vous pouvez vous dire oui enfin
bon moi je suis justement qu'une seule
goutte dans ce monde si vaste et bien
j'aimerais vous dire fermez vos yeux
imaginez alors être une goutte en effet
mais vous êtes entouré de huit milliards
de gouttes
ensemble vous êtes agglutinés les uns
les autres
qu'est-ce que vous formez on peut former
un océan
mais pas n'importe lequel on peut former
ensemble un océan du mieux vivre en
simple
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
dès demain ou même dès ce soir vous
pouvez distribuer un sac de charité en
bas de chez vous vous pouvez répondre à
un besoin de votre communauté trouver
une solution manger local pour aider
notre économie et soutenir nos petits
commerçants artisans ou simplement
partager les solutions de michel dubec
heures autour de vous
c'est aussi simple que ça l'echange mais
coeur les super héros dont vous parlez
au début en fait c'est vous vous avez
tous le pouvoir d'agir
vous avez tous le pouvoir de heal the
world
vous avez tous le pouvoir d'inspirer
peut-être garçon de 10 ans et pour
terminer comme disait mon super héros si
tu veux changer le monde commence par
changer la personne dans le miroir merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]